hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that was played in round five
so the first
game of the day uh in everything's
masters in the preliminaries
between magnus carlsen and daniel dubo
we already mentioned in the previous
video
that it's uh almost unimaginable to see
a game where duboff plays
and that it's not like a crazy
interesting game or something so let's
see how he does
uh against the world champion magnus
carlson and as most of you know dougal
was uh one of carlson's
seconds during his world champs
championship match against fabiana
corona
so he knows quite a lot of what magnus
knows
and can use this against him so let's
see how this game goes magnus has the
white pieces
and he opens with e4 double replies with
c5 goes for the sicilian
as magnus would we have knight to f3
knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 so uh
just uh attacking that knight going for
the rosso limo
we have g6 preparing to fiance to the
dark square bishop
and magnus just castles here with bishop
to g7 baidu both and now
captures on c6 so this is a well-known
line
b captures and rook to e1 and here
knight to h6 by do both
uh you don't want to develop it to f6 so
you allow e5 to come with tempo at any
point so
c3 uh and now comes castles by uh
double we have d4 magnus strikes in the
center
do both trades ones with captures
captures and now d5 or
preparing to trade in the center here uh
so magnus of course advances the pawn to
e5 and here
although it seems like white has a very
strong presence in the center you can
always undermine this with moves like c5
or as it was played in the game with f6
and this has all been played before
so it's nothing new uh for either of
them uh magnus goes h3
takes away the uh the g4 square from uh
dooba's bishop and here we have a trade
f captures on e5 d captures an e5 and
now c5 uh this position has been reached
before
uh it's been played once in the world
blitz women's championship 2018 between
leia
garifulina and natalya bookshop uh and
ended in a draw where knights to f7 was
played
uh so the knight was being remaneuvered
this way but here we have c5 by dubo
uh it's a new move so already as of move
12 uh we have a completely new game
now so what's happening here uh well uh
after c5 was played magnus instantly
replied with b4 and b4
is the top move recommended by the
engine so magnus knows
definitely what he's doing here so it's
not uh nothing like a delayed evans
gambit or anything it's
just a normal b4 move yeah you know you
you guys are so obsessed
so c captures on b4 that do both accepts
the pawn and now magnus offers
another one uh with a3 uh hoping for b
captures then bishop captures you get a
bishop
this very nice diagonal and you continue
development however duboff after this
uh a3 move goes d4 instead
and now magnus needs to decide does he
capture this pawn does he capture this
pawn with the knight
he could also capture this pawn with the
queen so a lot of possibilities here the
problem
uh with capturing with the queen queen
captures on d4
is that it doesn't yield anything for
white queen captures knight captures and
let's say after a a an offer of a knight
trade here
you could trade the captures captures
and now let's say a captures on b4
bishop captures on e5 grabs that e5 pawn
and nothing to it uh uh material is
equal yes black has three pawn islands
white has two but
not nothing much black has the bishop
pair let's play on both sides of the
board nothing much here for magnus
uh so instead after this d4 idea by
double we have
eight captures on b4 and now bishop to
b7 now do both fiance
both of his bishops and now the two of
them
will be extremely strong and i just want
to say sorry about the crackling sound
in the previous video i have no idea
what happened there i just uh you know
i made a test recording right after that
video and the sound was perfectly fine
so i have no idea why that happened
so really really sorry about that so
here bishop the b7 like i said the
double fianchettos is utter
bishop and now magnus again needs to
decide whether he goes for the pawn here
or does he try something different uh
here magnus goes knight b
to d2 and here he says okay you have to
be a little bit careful
i might play knights to e4 if you play
something like e6 i might
get a knight outpost for my knight on d6
so now dubo needs to figure out what to
do here and he plays the absolute best
move a5 he wants to trade uh
all the material here and open up the a
file for his rook and the magnus took
some three minutes here to decide what
to do
do you capture with the pawn or do you
trade first so here magnus decided to
capture with the
rook captures on a5 uh or radar knights
the e4 was also an option but
magnus decides to trade here rook
captures rook captures b
captures and the queen captures an a5
and only now
magnus captures on d4 and now after all
is said and done
uh magnus ends this uh well sort of
variation being up upon but
do both with the bishop pair it's an
extremely tricky position to play
for example uh if dubo were to try and
pick up the pawn back
magnus can simply play knight 2 to f3
attack the bishop now twice
also the knight is under attack so it
would be pretty pretty
bad to play this with black if bishop
goes back to defend the knight you can
even capture an e7
so it's a it's a much better position
for white so instead after magnus played
knight captures on d4 we have knight
to f5 by dubo offering a knight trade
and here uh although you could capture
knight captures rook captures and go
bishop to b2
uh queen to d5 can be very annoying just
going after that checkmate threat and
you'd have to trade queens like this
queen to b3
now you prevent checkmate by pinning the
queen and now after let's say rook f8
now you trade here
and you continue playing this position
it's perfectly fine white's still up
upon black still has the bishop pair
so it is possible but instead of this
knight captures uh we have
knight 4 to f3 so just going back with
the knight
and here queen to d5 by double now the
wolf says
okay my next plan is uh to go bishop to
h6 put pressure on the knight play rook
28 put more pressure on the knight
and magnus will have some uh trouble
moving pieces around if the knight moves
its queen to g2 checkmate and so on
uh might even use this as a thumbnail as
it's it's a pretty nice position
so uh here magnus went bishop to b2 so
he developed one more piece and now the
e51 is sufficiently defended
and uh uh he's not doing a great on the
clock but it's okay he's seven minutes
on the clock dubo is some 10 minutes on
the clock and duval continues with his
plan bishop to h6
now there's a double attack here and
rook to d8 is coming
and the magnus just continues with e6 he
says
this is not a problem i now opened up
this diagonal for my dark square bishop
and i'm enjoying my position being up a
pawn
so rook to d8 and now it's not all that
clear what you do here
the knight is attacked three times you
cannot move it as then just queen
captures queen
and uh if you play something like rook
to e2 then queen to b5
just uh shatters your position the
bishop is under attack if you move the
bishop somewhere uh just bishop captures
an f3
you remove one of the defenders here the
knight cannot capture because the queen
falls
and after g captures your entire
position just falls apart knight h4
and that's it white will lose this in a
few moves so instead after rook 28
magnus
uh almost uh instantly plays queen to e2
as you don't kind of play pawn to e6 on
the previous move without seeing queen
to e2
so now the point is if you go after this
if you try and capture it let's say
bishop captures you just pin the bishop
rook d1
and now after the queen moves then you
pick up your piece rook captures through
captures knight captures and again you
continue this position
enjoying your extra pawn so instead
after queen e2
dubai goes queen to d3 he offers a queen
trade and now magnus accepts because
uh he's up upon and once the queen
queens come off the board uh
he he cannot be worse in this position
because for
for one thing there are pawns on only
one side of the board
and the bishop player will not be all
that impressive so queen captures rook
captures on d3
and now knight the e4 by magnus uh we
have bishop captures on e4
like i said the bishop pair is no longer
fully operational so dubois gives up one
of them
rook captures and now bishop to g7 and
the situation on the clock is
magnus three minutes due of five minutes
for those of you who are just joining in
after you make a move you get 10 seconds
increment
so bishop the e5 magnus offers a trade
on e5 now
and dubo accepts we have captures and
knight captures and
now rook to d1 check king to h2 and king
to g7
and now uh if you let two computers play
play play this position out of course
it's a draw but these are not computers
these are very
fine gentlemen and they are very low on
time so let's see what happens here
g4 attacking this knight here with
knight back to d6 and
now you want to play f4 but you don't
want to play f4 too soon as
for example now your rook is under
attack so look back to e3
and now they're almost equal in time
dubo took some time to
uh consider about that knight move so
they're about three and a half minutes
each here
so rookie three and now g5 double really
needs to stop that f4 idea
so king g2 and now h6 by double
uh we ignite the c6 by magnus making
moves really quickly
as the title suggests uh you have to use
the clock as a weapon so knight c6
king to f6 and now rook to f3 with
check this is how magnus forces do both
to capture on e6 because if you move the
rook then it's a free pawn so dubo has
to capture
now comes rook back to e3 with check now
there's a double attack on the e7 pawn
king gives a six and now uh uh knight
captures on e7 so magnus still up upon
but they're
on the same side of the board it's going
to be incredibly difficult
to convert this into a full point so
knight c4 attacking carlson's rook he
goes
rookie four and double quickly repeats
knight to b6
as you know if it's a three-fold
repetition then the game ends in a draw
so magnus goes back
rook to e2 and now rook to d3
again preventing the white king from
entering the position with
knight to c6 and now knight to f7 by
duboff
dubo just needs to play moves that don't
lose and
he needs to not waste more time so
that's that's his plan
rook to e3 by magnus uh he's trying to
trade off rooks because the knights are
very tricky
and magnus likes his chances in a three
against two with
only knights on the board uh of course
if you trade knights then the game is
pretty much instantly at raw
so here offers a rook trade of course to
do both declines rook back to d7
and now rook rook to a3 by magnus again
using the clock as a weapon
as other than that you don't have a
really a viable plant here
so knights the h8 by duboff putting the
knight on the
on the rim is often grim but here it
comes with a with a good plan actually
knight the g6 to f4 or h4 will be
a very strong piece there knight the b8
magnus does
the same it comes with an attack on the
rook rook b7 attacking here
uh the knight and now uh rook the a6
check first
king g7 and only now knight the c6 so
knights to g6 by dubof
and knights the d for now and here just
knight h4 check
so double uh completed his plan of
shifting the knight all the way to h4
uh we have king to g3 and now comes rook
the b1 by do both here rook the b4
was much better attacking that knight
and well
a lot of other things but duval played
rook to b1
as he was very low on the clock so now
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the move do both missed while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on being a master
of the end game
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's f4
this is what do love allowed and this is
not a problem because it allows magnus
to immediately create a pass pawn
and of course you cannot capture the
pawn because then the knight hangs on h4
so although the knight on h4 is very
impressive also
comes with a price so here duba finds
the only reasonable defense
rook the g1 check came to f2 now rook to
g2
check king to f1 and now again the
problem is
you cannot capture on f4 and this is a
dubose big problem because if you
capture just knight f5 check
and you either lose the knight here or
you capture the knight and then you lose
the rook and again the position is lost
so here after uh carlsen's king f1 rook
to d2 is
played attacking the knight and now
knight to e6 with
check again coming with a double attack
on g5
king to f7 uh and now comes uh
f captures and g5 so grabbing that pawn
and here not capturing right away but
rather going knight to f3
first with h captures on g5 it's still
possible to maybe try to defend this but
dubois played
knight to f3 uh he wanted to get a
standard uh
standard drawing uh setup because here
at night the h2 check and so on would be
a perpetual check and you would be able
to draw this
uh but uh the problem is now it's
completely lost so feel free to pause
the video
and win this game for magnus as there is
only one move that does that
so enjoy
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding the
only move on the board that wins
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's
no it's not that it's actually g6 check
and now
the problem is you cannot capture it
because if the pawn is captured
knight to d4 with check uh opens up a
discovery and picks up the knight on f3
so black loses a piece in the game
so here after g6 you are forced to move
away from the past pawn of course
you cannot go here the knight guards
that you cannot go here you could go
here but
then of course you run into the very
ugly checkmate rook they
check all these three squares are
covered so you'd have to block and this
of course would be checkmate
so not possible so after this g6 check
double is forced to go the other way
king to e7
but now comes rook to a3 and this is
another great move by magnus here
because if he was
greedy going for g7 uh then uh
he allows dubois this very well known uh
drawing sequence knight h2 check
king e1 attacks the rook but now knight
f3 check defense the rook checks the
king
you have to go back 92 check he goes
here knight f3 checking f1
it's a very very good uh technique to
know you know if you ever run into a
position like this so after this king to
a7 move magnus not rushing with this
but ryder plays rook to a3 the rook is
now
helping out with the defense here so now
it would be pointless to attempt such a
thing
so here dubois does go knight stage two
but after king e1 now of course you
don't have the option of going back
because the rook covers that
so rook to d6 was played and now comes
knight to f4 and magnus now has three
pawns
uh against one also the g6 one is nicely
protected
and dubo has no way of getting that
knight into the game as the rook still
covers the f3 square
so king of six is played and here king
to e2 and here dubo was below 10 seconds
on the clock
he played rook to d7 and now rook to a6
with
check king e5 and now comes knight to h5
uh and it was in this position that
daniel dubo resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
this is this is happening
if you try something like rook b7 maybe
even to harass the white king doesn't
really matter
g7 you're gonna block the queening
square but now rook to f6
and there's no defense against rook f8
you will block
black's rook and that's it if you try a
couple of checks just king d3 rugby
three checking c2 or whatever and
now it's completely lost you have to go
back here
here you go uh blocking this and now in
the next move you get a queen
uh i only play that because i know you
guys enjoy it so much
uh so really interesting what happened
here and
as we've uh we made a lot of dooba
videos uh
over the past few days and i know you
guys started to really really enjoy his
games and as you can see he's still
playing creatively he
put everything into this game it's the
first game of the day and he was really
trying to
go all out with that fully operational
bishops pair
but magnus is just annoyingly strong and
uh you know he he just crushed duo's
hopes and dreams here
uh but uh you know if if it was someone
someone else who doesn't
you know grind for the win like magnus
dubo would most likely have
drawn this game having the bishop pair
or most likely even won the game
uh but yeah magnus is annoyingly strong
and this is what happens he
he he tends to crush creative players
which is a shame because we like
creative players to win but it is as it
is
uh so yeah magnus gets his first win of
the tournament we'll see what happens
next
uh so i do hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank
tom duralal duras press david bacon
russell light and timothy roson for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of the this very nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and uh whatever else happens
in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day